comienzo precisamente con esos choques
de los que usted está hablando porque
esta manifestación es hasta hace unos
pocos instantes se desarrollaba en
completa calma en un muy buen ambiente y
un poquito festivo Incluso el ambiente
Pero ha habido varios momentos de
disturbios momentos de muchísima
atención entre la policía antimotines y
algunos manifestantes especialmente esos
Black que son aquellos son jóvenes Pues
que se dedican a a romper vitrinas ha
habido bastantes
canecas que han nacido incendiadas y con
el problema que hay además de la huelga
de las personas que recogen basura pues
esto no ha ayudado Así que también hemos
visto a los bomberos en plena acción
aquí donde me encuentro estoy un poco
alejada de donde debe pasar la
manifestación sobre la calle que ustedes
ven justamente allí detrás mío y las
personas están en realidad tratando de
salir de ese gran Bulevar porque es allí
donde se han presentado muchísimos
muchísima atención aquí alrededor hay
policía antimotin varios jóvenes que han
sido arres nosotros los hemos visto
venir desde esta desde esta calle donde
Está realizando esta manifestación así
como varios policías que han resultado
heridos los hemos visto pasar también
aquí por nuestro lado heridos
principalmente en las piernas pero como
les decía bastante tensión en este en
este momento en este punto cuando ya
estábamos llegando al punto final a
donde debía llegar esta manifestación
que es en ópera mucha afluencia en estas
marchas no solo en París también en el
resto del país Natalia el presidente
Manuel macron insiste en que esta
reforma pensional será promulgada a
finales de año y en las calles el sentir
es de continuar así las cosas Cuál es
ese entonces el panorama al que se
enfrenta el país
bueno el panorama es que continúa ese
pulso entre los franceses que continúan
en la calle y el gobierno que como usted
bien lo decía continúa siendo
completamente inflexible a pesar de que
hoy pues según los sindicatos ya son
unas 800,000 personas las que estarían
desfilando solamente aquí en París Esa
es la cifra que las autoridades tenían
estimada solamente en todo en toda
Francia ahora como les decía continúa
ese pulso hoy se esperaba también saber
o tomar un poco la atención de lo que
sería este movimiento y por lo visto
pues los franceses no se han sentido
derrotados por lo que haya sucedido en
la asamblea nacional a comienzos de esta
semana sino que continúan en las calles
firmes pidiendo que se retire esta
reforma Ahora hay que esperar justamente
el texto de esta de esta ley que va a
ser estudiado por el consejo
constitucional y luego de eso también
hay otra posibilidad que ese ese
referéndum la idea de someter a
referendo este texto de ley Esta es otra
de las opciones para muchos franceses
eso es lo que tiene que ocurrir pero
para ello pues se necesitan recolectar
al menos unos a cuatro millones de
firmas así que por ahora Pues como
ustedes ven Esto no se no se calma los
franceses no solamente están muy
descontentos con lo que los lo que
sucedió sino también el método que ha
empleado el gobierno es decir ese
cuarenta y nueve tres pasar esta reforma
a la fuerza y también acá de lo que
hemos visto pues muchos piden también la
renuncia de la primera ministra
Elizabeth